hey youtubers is charlie is gonna be my
got them finale video
generally it did live up to a little bit
in the high PT some really big things to
the second half to the season so
amana also talk about might just general
thoughts on the season in addition to
justice episode
since we're heading into the winter
break leave all your request for bonus
videos in the comments below
looking forward to doing a lot about me
and videos careful for spoilers from the
episode if you're not cut up
but 30 with top elements number five
falcone
verses the mob taken to bury the lead in
the last episode when the Blue is money
up
for the most part it was meant to be
like that Joker scene from Dark Knight
where he does burns all the mods money
that's not what they did to me they blew
apart a bit but the other half is Pisces
by the police
you just it'd be like a crazy amount of
money which is why I'm surprised they
waited till this episode to show
falcone's reaction
it's pretty clear that lies is the one
that informed on the location the money
lies in Prajna can lead to see season
two I am a little frustrated with how
easy it seems
for them to pull a fast one on falcone
but you don't rise to the rank %uh
mob boss at his level without being
really smart
feminine got them are detective shows so
I'm expecting a little bit more
detective work
from some other characters number for
penguin verses fish Mooney
the biggest question is Is why is he
biding his time when I just take her out
now
he could be trying to do the same thing
to fish mooney the fish munies trying to
do too falcone
pick as fish slowly gets more powerful
Penguins
slowly weasel his way in so we'll have a
bigger pie to steal
when it comes time to take over her
organization or take her power in some
way
Penguins family the couple pots are
historically wealthy people but
I don't think he's focused so much on
the money aspect as much as the power
we really started out with falcone in a
couple mob players
now we're starting to see people from
the Wayne foundation are
from the wing border directors that's on
the biggest criticism to the show
is it they're introducing too many
villains too many big characters
we'll see how that goes I mean a given
benefited out right now
but most my attention is on penguin and
his
small circle that includes fish movie
bulk own in Maroni
who we did not see in this episode all
the character arcs this season I feel
like they've served as the Penguins the
most
I mean a really put him forward is one
of the big protagonist the series
even if he's
can like an anti-hero 10 degrees a
villain but he's also kinda not a
villain in the way they're presenting in
just because there people there so much
worse than he is number three
batman & Catwoman I really let their
scenes together i mean the right play
pool
and that is really fun dimension to the
show that supposed to be super dark
generally I tried to ignore my call that
stunt work
it felt a little formulaic like it was
something out like a full house episode
but then jumping around the rooftops and
having fun like them devising await
to get rid of copper head in the people
telling them there been a lot other
comic book shows they're taking that
gritty hand-held approach
images kinda spoils you in terms of
action
really we need to blame a row for doing
action so well base at the bar so high
that now
a time something is set up in isn't done
hand-held it seems
kinda lame and I made the comment
earlier that got them stunt work just
isn't quite as good as their
I feel like bill get there eventually I
mean this on the first season
darrell has gotten a lot better over
time that's what I'm expecting from
cotton to
but I would like to see more of his like
was really awkward moments like with ID
pepper
or poison ivy everyone I think about her
she was a lotta fun just watching her
totally creep everyone out
and a lot of people aren't big fans have
children on shows the response to take
themselves
pretty seriously I don't think I can
take itself too seriously
but I be like their best used in scenes
like this
so just generally expecting less stunt
work from the kids
more actual kids stuff ok if you like
big induced up the normal kids we do
like they can get into trouble in also
be fun to watch
they don't need to do you like Batman
level stuns number two
the mir verses cordon Richard kind so
great as a semi
gone take character in this episode the
mayor's rearing its head
he's like institutionalized evil it's
like he's got his process
he's gonna follow it he doesn't think
about it being good or evil
just like this is gonna do whatever this
is the way it works
the same comment was made about the
hunters on Walking Dead
institutionalized evil only in that case
it was cannibalism
so it is kinda funny to think that the
mayor of Gotham is being a cannibal
I don't think it's the direction they're
going that would be pretty crazy though
the only thing I didn't like was when
Gordon told him to kiss his ass I felt
like I was almost
unintentionally hilarious as a curator
the mayor's down a lot more interesting
he's way more interesting when he's
being evil like this clearly
whoever is really behind the murder is
influencing him
he probably knows who it is this said
that there was a run
on way in stock clearly whoever actually
initiated the murder
was the one that started that but I
think that the reason the mayor got so
pissed according is
is because tearing down the pillars the
community even if they're only perceive
pillars
which is cause more chaos this you get
to institutionalize people
records trying to do the right thing but
the mayor's trying to do the best thing
but the best thing in the been pretty
terrible the big question after this
though
is who sent Copperhead she's into the
character from the comics oh that's fun
to see here
but you can pick up her is like you know
serb penguin level bill and penguin is
like an a-list Batman villain
Copperhead very awesome in this episode
but
relatively minor character by comparison
in my number one mom in
Gordon goes to Arkham I feel like we've
been waiting for this all season
Gordon is art to get in so I'm actually
really glad that the show did this
in the context of the story I mean he's
pissed is still trying to find out who
killed the way and so he's not quitting
the ports like they wanted to
what i think is gonna end up happening
is is that would you spend the second
half of the season
inside Arkham Asylum will get to me Hugo
Strange
in a whole bunch other new characters
it'll bring on they have announced
everyone
Hugo Strange is just one of the bigger
ones let me know that was your payment
from the episode
and he's maybe question for you guys
which Batman don't do you want to see
inside Arkham do you think they have a
realistic chance to bring on
I do think they're paving the way for
Joker and they did say that they would
be able to do at some point I'm it's
going to be a long time
that kinda been ambiguous time line so
it could be season 2 could be season 3
and we don't even know for going to get
a season two yet I think the odds are
pretty good
to get a full-season pickup the 20
episode order pretty early
just over on general I had to give the
finale be and
unload a harder on been allies the name
on other episodes just because
so much extra work goes into them so you
expect a much bigger payoff
really the big winner to come out in
this episode is in terms of performance
is Alfred
we doing all season to watch him kick
some butt
got a few teases but finally we get to
see him really throw down
you do not cast the summer the doctor
without letting him kick some butt
really offer did spend most the episode
just trampling
all over the big characters like cut the
bullshit
where's Bruce Wayne if you like Ben
McKenzie was just a little too on the
nose
at the end if you think he's taking his
character have cordoned
more seriously like way more seriously
than the other actors are taking their
characters
got them as a show generally feels like
it's supposed to be like to find cheese
in between a row in the flashes ham
sandwich so expected to be a little bit
funny little bit campy like that classic
TV series the sixties TV series
is both a Tim Burton Batman films they
got 10 more episodes
so I think he's gonna have a lot more
fun inside Arkham
hopefully that comes across in his
performance playing a big character like
important carries a lot of baggage with
it so a given the benefit of the doubt
their lot a TV series that I really
loved over the years like Stargate for
instance
to leave ridiculous in its first couple
seasons got really good
past like season 3 45 that happens all
the time with TV shows
especially long-running ones like to hit
their stride a certain point
sometimes it takes a whole year I will
see just in general
Arkham Asylum could be a show by itself
so if cotton does
well enough over time they could spin
often do in Arkham show
achieve kinda feel like often should
have been that like to be much more
entertaining
governors interesting me. gotten
Central's a great comic and it's really
easy to do turns to character just to
unite the paper so many licenses brother
costumes for superman to deal with
superpowers but if you gonna do a dark
gritty Batman show there is no better
place than Arkham Asylum
so in the annals the TV history as we
move into season two you are
however long got the runs for when
people ask me about the show
I'm I just tell them to start watching
but the second half a season 1
like when we get inside Arkham there's
one other thing but I'm not a big fan up
with TV shows nowadays made up stuff
because been so much time sitting
characters up
when a lot of times I feel like we all
know who those characters are so
y de need to do that word in stories
again manages get right to the point
marvelous star needed that with their
films a little bit but less
origin stories more just start
up with the characters with their powers
in their comic book identities
give you know who Captain America is you
don't need to show him becoming captain
america:
when I just have him be Captain America
Inc on whatever adventure you want to
send them on
that issue in a really good question for
you guys let me know in the comments
do you care about origin stories or
would you just rather see
villains in the other heroes they bring
on the show start out
where they are in the comics I really do
feel like it's a bloody time
but I don't think that hollywood's gonna
banned in origin stories anytime soon
there's just too many people did do not
be comics to just a quick reminder
gotten is gonna be up there for a couple
weeks is gonna be on break they have an
announcement coming back yet
but I will post that in like 10 my flash
or a row videos cuz
that has a couple more episodes to go
for those shows speedy which new plans
tonight
she gets real so be sure to subscribe to
get that video oppose
later tonight once we get through the
finale's have all these comic book shows
also rank how I thought you to them did
relative to each other
far away though I feel like heroes gonna
come out the clear winner
but if you like flash is giving got them
a run for its money right now
in just a quick reminder new mobile link
secure the top it seems the link the
night over here
but click here for last week's got them
in click here for my flash video of was
that later tonight
thank you so much watching for the
hotpot see had little bit
up